did you know that like everybody is gay
now
did you know like every single person
not just every single person in the
country that's not quite true but gen z
and the people coming after them are
super
duper gay and all the other like lbt all
of them
pascal emanuel gobre from the ethics and
public policy center just posted this
graph from statista
shows in 2014
uh the percentage of the population that
identified as lgbt
you saw it was
a little
like somewhere around two percent for
the
silent generation born before 1946
somewhere around two and a half percent
for baby boomers somewhere around maybe
three percent for gen x and about six or
seven percent for millennials
okay all right fair enough
then 2017 they took the same snapshot
remained about the same for the silent
generation of the boomers and gen x but
it went up for millennials went up to
like eight percent
then they're doing that now stays about
the same for
silent generation and gen x and the
boomers
goes up even more to like 9.1 percent
for millennials
15.9
for gen z
i'm not denying that there is some
uh potentially natural basis for
sexual desires and things
human beings are complicated it's a
fallen world everyone's got some strange
sort of uh aspects to their psyche and
especially sex is so important to human
nature
but there's got to be like some kind of
social factor here right
unless alex jones is completely right
and there's just something in the water
and they're turning the frickin frogs
gay and they're turning the frickin
zoomers gay
clearly there is some kind of social
philosophical psychological spiritual
factor
going on here
and i pointed out not to castigate
anything or anyone just to point out
the conservatives were right when when
the conservatives said this is a
slippery slope and you know these kinds
of
uh sexual ideologies are going to spread
throughout the society and then the lib
said that's not true and that's
ridiculous and what are you talking
about
it it was true we were we were right
society is never neutral and this is a
lesson not just
for the libs to learn this is a lesson
for the libertarians to learn as well
and some of the conservatives who want
to say well look i'm going to do me you
do you
what you do doesn't affect me
everyone should just do whatever they
want as long as it doesn't scare the
horses in the streets
it's not how it works
we live in society
we develop based on other people
very few people in the history of the
world have ever lived alone in the woods
we live in society and the way that
other people behave the way that other
people
structure their desires even are going
to affect everyone else
and that's why these problems are not
just individual and they're not even
just cultural to be addressed by the
private enterprise they're political
they're properly political as well and
to answer whoopi goldberg's question how
dare you
espouse an opinion about this how dare i
because i got a brain and i got a
conscience and because i am a citizen
darling ring that bill
please
thank you i appreciate it that way
you'll get notifications if you don't
get notifications you want to also
subscribe to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five-star
review if you don't mind i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]